Доброго дня, шановні учні.
Я, Мартинюк Олена, сьогодні
проводжу разом із вами
урок історії України за 10 клас.
І тема нашого уроку:
«Карпатська Україна».
За традицією, вже складеною
моєю колегою Ольгою Дудар,
починаємо з перевірки
домашнього завдання.
Пані Ольга дала вам
надзвичайно цікаве завдання.
Це прокласти туристичний маршрут
Закарпаттям і подумати,
де б ви збудували готель.
Завдання було настільки цікаве,
що я так само стала думати,
а де, справді, я пройшла б стежками
Закарпаття, де я побудувала б готель.
Але все це треба було
транслювати на 20-30 роки.
І ось пам'ятаючи, що в той час
у Закарпатті дуже був розвинутий спорт,
закарпатці захоплювались футболом,
тенісом, верховою їздою,
велосипедним спортом,
я подумала, що, можливо,
для молоді було б дуже цікаво пройти
пішки і дізнатися для пластунів маршрут.
Подивіться, чудова Долина нарцисів.
Але треба пройти з краю так
обережно, щоб не пошкодити
реліктові рослини, які тут збереглися.
Також для любителів екзотики
і чогось такого страшного
можна було б запропонувати
провести ніч у Хусті,
у таємничих руїнах замку Влада Дракули.
І, нарешті, для людей,
які мають певні статки,
але мають певні проблеми зі здоров'ям,
а можливо, і просто хочуть відпочити,
я б таки порадила збудувати
готель у Берегово.
Там чудові мінеральні джерела,
де можна поправити своє здоров'я.
Ну і, звісно, чудовий вірш
пані Ольга читала,
це був вірш Олександра Олеся
«Як прекрасна царівна».
І ми переходимо з вами до теми
нашого сьогоднішнього уроку:
«Карпатська Україна».
Наш урок є прямим продовженням
попереднього уроку,
де ви вивчали українські землі
у складі Чехословаччини.
Давайте ми дещо з вами
спробуємо пригадати.
Ще з ХІІІ століття Закарпаття
було у складі Угорщини.
Угорці докладали всіх зусиль для того,
щоб денаціоналізувати українців,
зробити їх мадярами.
Послухайте, що писав Олександр Духнович
у середині ХІХ століття.
Слова Духновича підтверджує зізнання
і одного зі священників,
який категорично заявляв…
Через 20 років Михайло Драгоманов,
який двічі побував
у Закарпатті, з сумом писав…
Здавалося б, що вже зовсім втратили
закарпатці своє розуміння,
етнічне походження, та ні.
Здавалося б, вогник згас, але іноді
достатньо пориву свіжого вітру,
щоб вогник національної ідентичності
знову розгорівся з новою силою.
На жаль, таким навіть не вогником,
а справжнім полум'ям стало полум'я
Першої світової війни.
Саме в цьому полум’ї багато народів
іще більше усвідомили
свою національну приналежність
і, користуючись тим, що імперії ослабли,
такі недержавні народи,
тобто які не мали своєї держави,
у тому числі українці,
вирішили поборотись за свою державність.
Були серед них і закарпатці.
Зверніть увагу на слайд.
Після закінчення Першої світової війни
закарпатці виразили своє бажання.
21 грудня 1918 року в Мукачево
закарпатці проголосили
автономію Руської Крайни
у складі Угорщини.
Ось де далася взнаки ця мадяризація.
Але 21 січня 1919 року в Хусті
всенародні збори русинів-українців
ухвалили приєднати Закарпаття
до Соборної України.
Ось вогонь національного пробудження.
Не вдалося мадярам повністю
нівелювати українство.
Але, якщо ви дивилися мій
попередні урок всесвітньої історії,
то там я зовнішнє втручання
визначала червоним кольором.
Так само і тут.
У березні–квітні 1919 року Закарпаття
захопила Угорська Радянська Республіка.
Проте ненадовго.
Уже в квітні країни Антанти
приймають рішення
передати Закарпаття Чехословаччині.
Зверніть увагу, ніхто не питає
думки своїх закарпатців.
Іноземні країни вільно
вирішують долю цілих народів.
Якщо в Румунії, у Польщі відбувалися
всілякі утиски українців,
то в Чехії таких прямих утисків
загалом ми не спостерігаємо.
Але держава і не дуже й допомагала
розвиткові українського народу.
Увага на екран.
Вже в 1929 році учасники першого
з'їзду молоді Закарпаття заявили:
«Проголошуємо всьому
культурному світові, що ми,
підкарпатські русини, є частиною
великого українського народу
і що наша мова та наша література
була, є і буде та сама,
що в наших братів з того боку Карпат».
І знову ми бачимо втручання
іноземних держав.
Мюнхенська угода, 30 вересня 1938 року.
Учасники цієї наради і підписання
цієї угоди: Невілл Чемберлен,
прем'єр-міністр Французької
республіки Едуард Даладьє,
далі ви бачите Адольфа Гітлера,
далі стоїть прем'єр-міністр
Королівства Італії Беніто Муссоліні
і поруч із Муссоліні – міністр
закордонних справ Італії Галеаццо Чіано.
Саме вони підписують Мюнхенську угоду.
Заради чого вони зібралися?
Подивімося наступний слайд.
Зверніть увагу на карикатуру.
Перша карикатура – явно радянська.
Вона підписана російською мовою.
Що ми бачимо на карикатурі?
Два пани, один із них явно
англієць, інший – француз,
підносять голодному вовку, у якому ми
явно вгадуємо Гітлера, шматок м'яса.
А щоб ніхто не переплутав, що це,
то там навіть написано «Чехословаччина»
і прапорець.
Як справжні дресирувальники,
вони вказують голодному вовкові,
що він має зробити за отримане
м’яско – «на схід».
На конференції не були присутні
представники Америки,
але Радянський Союз явно
дає зрозуміти глядачам,
що тут присутня і Америка,
он навіть дядя Сем,
його тінь спостерігається при цьому,
тобто з дозволу Америки.
Як ми здогадалися, що відбувається у нас
на Мюнхенській конференції,
Гітлеру віддають Чехословаччину.
Подивімося на інший слайд.
Це карикатура з англійської газети.
Що ми бачимо?
Знову та сама четвірка,
але в дверях стоїть фігура,
в якій явно вгадується Йосип Сталін.
І він запитує: «Де моє крісло?»
Чим зайняті учасники цієї угоди?
А вони ділять Чехословаччину, он вона,
на задньому плані на карті,
але подивіться, будь ласка, автор цієї
карикатури явно дає зрозуміти їхні плани.
А їхні плани – це поділ світу,
а Чехословаччина – це тільки початок.
Отже, основний зміст угоди.
1. Судетська область, яка населялася
переважно німцями,
відділяється від Чехословацької
республіки
і передається Третьому Рейху
з 1 по 10 жовтня.
2. Усе майно, у тому числі зброя,
укріплення, особисті речі, худоба,
меблі громадян мають залишатися на місці.
3. Чехословацька республіка
протягом трьох місяців повинна
задовольнити територіальні претензії
Польської республіки
та Королівства Угорщини.
А тепер уявіть собі, перед нами карта.
Ось у нас Судетська область, яка таким
півколом охоплює Чехословаччину.
Якщо Чехословаччина
мала віддати Німеччині,
причому протягом десяти днів,
всі свої укріплення,
все майно і не мала права
нічого вивести звідти.
У якій ситуації опинилася Чехословаччина?
Навіть маючи одну з найкращих
армій у Європі на той час,
вона стала абсолютно беззбройною.
Вона надалі не могла чинити опір агресії
з боку Німеччини та інших держав.
У таких обставинах і закарпатські
українці вирішили, що настав час,
нарешті, вирішити проблему
автономії Карпатської України,
яка була обіцяна українцям
іще в 1918-1919 роках,
коли підписувалися Сен-Жерменський
та Тріанонський договори.
Так, ще 29 травня 1938 року
Центральна Рада Руської Народної Ради
поставила вимогу до уряду Чехословаччини
про надання їй статусу автономії краю.
Проте вона його так і не отримала.
9 вересня 1938 року
до Праги прибуває делегація
з десяти представників
Української Центральної Народної Ради
ще раз проводити переговори
про статус автономії Карпатської України
у Чехословацькій державі.
Як би розвивались події,
зараз важко сказати,
але тут у нас саме й сталася 30 вересня
1938 року Мюнхенська угода.
А в продовження
Мюнхенської угоди 4 жовтня
будапештський уряд запропонував Німеччині
передати Закарпаття до Угорщини.
За таких обставин 8 жовтня
1938 року було утворено
Перший автономний уряд
Підкарпатської Русі.
Очолив його Андрій Бродій.
Цей уряд і проголосив автономію
Підкарпатської Русі.
Уряд складався з двох груп:
русофілів, яких представляли
А. Бродій, Е. Бачинський, І. П’єщак,
і українофілів – Ю. Ревай, А. Волошин.
Проте уже 26 жовтня Бродія було усунуто
з посади голови Кабінету Міністрів
і заарештовано за державну
зраду і шпигунство.
Стало відомо, що Андрій Бродій
вів активні переговори з угорцями
щодо передання Закарпатської України
під владу Угорщини.
Прем’єр-міністром стає Августин Волошин,
який був лідером
Народно-християнської партії,
що мала проукраїнський напрямок.
Августин Волошин – знаменита
фігура у Закарпатті.
Він із сім'ї потомствених
греко-католицьких священиків.
Сам греко-католицький священик.
Брав активну участь
у суспільному житті Закарпаття.
Директор вчительської
семінарії в Ужгороді,
заснував Народно-християнську
партію і від неї обирався послом
до чехословацького парламенту.
Докладав неабияких зусиль для того,
щоб вибороти для Закарпаття автономію.
Не встиг сформуватись уряд,
не встигли ще нічого зробити,
тільки почали свій процес
державотворення,
як 2 листопада 1938 року відбувся
Перший віденський арбітраж.
Там якраз і вирішували забаганки Польщі
та Угорщини стосовно земель,
які вони хотіли отримати.
Перший віденський арбітраж відібрав
від Карпатської України територію,
ось вона позначена червоною
лінією, і від Словаччини.
Долю тепер Карпатської України,
долю Словаччини вирішували
міністри закордонних справ,
тобто справа раніше була
вирішена вже на вищому рівні.
А тут були присутні міністр
закордонних справ Німеччини
Йоахім фон Ріббентроп і міністр
закордонних справ Італії
Галеаццо Чіано, до речі, він
був зятем Беніто Муссоліні.
За таких обставин, щоб запобігти
остаточному розвалу Чехословаччини,
чехословацький уряд приймає
Конституційний закон
22 листопада 1938 року.
І цей закон проголошує
автономію Карпатської України.
Увага на екран.
Параграф перший.
1. Підкарпатська Русь є автономною
складовою частиною
Чехословацької Республіки.
2. Назву автономної території
південно-карпатських русинів
установить закон Сойму
Підкарпатської Русі.
До речі, спочатку назва була
Підкарпатська Русь.
Це була офіційна назва, хоча самі
закарпатці називали Карпатська Україна.
Але чеський уряд поки що дозволу
на таку назву не давав.
Тому в офіційних документах
вживалося «Підкарпатська Русь».
3. Урядову мову та мову навчання в
школах на території Підкарпатської Русі
встановить закон Сойму
Підкарпатської Русі.
Відповідно до цього
Конституційного закону
і проводив свою діяльність
уряд Августина Волошина.
По-перше, відповідно
до Віденського арбітражу,
Угорщина відразу окупувала
частину України.
І після того, як було захоплено Ужгород,
уряд перемістився у Хуст.
30 грудня 1938 року була
запроваджена нова назва краю,
яку і хотіли закарпатці, –
«Карпатська Україна».
У січні 1939 року було засновано
Українське національне об'єднання.
У Карпатській Україні
працювали українські школи.
Було відкрито 50 нових
міських і сільських шкіл.
Виходив щоденник «Нова свобода».
До Хуста приїхали відомі
українські письменники
Олександр Олесь,
Улас Самчук, які створили
літературно-мистецьке
товариство «Говерля».
Під редакцію Олега Ольжича-Кандиби
видавався місячник
із такою самою назвою – «Говерля».
Тобто ми бачимо, що в цей
час активно розвивається
національно-культурне життя
західних українців.
У цей самий час було створено Організацію
народної оборони «Карпатська Січ».
9 листопада 1938 року вважається
офіційним днем її заснування.
Хоча «Карпатська Січ» існувала
і до цього у вигляді спортивних гуртків.
Але зараз, у листопаді 1938 року,
у неї була зовсім інша мета –
це протистояти постійним нападам
угорських і польських терористів.
Очолив «Карпатську Січ» Дмитро Климпуш.
1 січня, до речі, 1939 року
було створено і Жіночу Січ.
Її очолила Стефанія Тисовська.
Чим же займалася «Карпатська Січ»?
Організовували художні вечори, вистави,
розповсюджували українську літературу,
жінки шили однострої чоловічі й жіночі,
національні та січові прапори.
Тут варто зазначити
про особливість «Карпатської Січі».
Як би не хотілося цим нашим
молодим хлопцям стати реально
на захист своєї молодої автономії,
це у них виходило дуже проблематично.
Чому? Перш за все була
велика проблема у зброї.
Зброї дістати було ніде, а Чехословаччина
не поспішала надавати їм зброю,
побоюючись, що вони можуть
повернути її зовсім в інший бік.
Тому з великими проблемами
діставали хто що міг
і тренувалися на чому було.
Проводили навчання, часто використовуючи
замість реальної зброї її макети,
але готувалися до оборони
рідної Батьківщини.
12 лютого 1939 року відбулася знаменна
подія для Карпатської України –
відбулися вибори до Сойму.
Подивіться, будь ласка, пропагандистський
плакат «У своїй хаті – своя правда».
За що він агітує?
Звісно, за незалежність.
Це була перемога, це була перемога
справжнього українського духу.
Зверніть увагу, 92,4 відсотка
здобули кандидати
Українського Національного Об'єднання,
яке виступало за державну
самостійність України.
Саме ці вибори дали можливість
15 березня 1939 року
проголосити повну державну
самостійність Карпатської України.
З цієї нагоди Августин Волошин
виголосив промову.
«Солодкий мій народе!
Ти не є вже тим пониженим рабом,
тим нещасним рутеном,
яким тебе колись з презирством
прозивали чужі пани,
але що ти є сином великої нації
Святого Володимира і Ярослава Мудрого».
Карпатці на повний голос заявили
про свою готовність створити незалежну
державу і цим розпочати справу
визволення всієї України.
10 березня, виступаючи
на XVIII з'їзд ВКП(б), Йосип Сталін
з цієї нагоди глузливо заявив:
«Комашка, що хоче приєднати слона»,
але ця комашка була надзвичайно відважна.
Річ у тім, що вже 14 березня
агресію почала знову Угорщина.
І саме за умов угорської агресії
проголошувалася
незалежність Карпатської України.
Карпатський Сойм прийняв конституційний
закон про незалежність і ухвалив:
назва держави – Карпатська Україна.
Перед вами той самий історичний документ,
який проголошував незалежність
Карпатської України, з підписами.
Державний устрій –
президентська республіка.
Державна мова – українська.
Державний прапор – синьо-жовтий.
Гімн – «Ще не вмерла Україна».
Герб – червоний ведмідь на лівому
срібному півколі і чотири сині
та три жовті смуги в правому півколі
та тризуб з хрестом на середньому зубі.
Президентом Карпатської України
було обрано Августина Волошина,
прем'єр-міністром нового уряду суверенної
держави призначили Юліана Ревая.
У цей час під Хустом уже йшли бої.
Відразу після проголошення незалежності
Августин Волошин звертається
до Гітлера з проханням
захистити Карпатську Україну,
але це прохання було відкинуто
і посол Німеччини передав фактично наказ:
без бою віддати угорцям
Карпатську Україну.
Августин Волошин відкидає цей ультиматум
і «Карпатська Січ» стає
на захист молодої держави.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу на ці слайди.
На першій світлині – міністр оборони
Карпатської України Степан Клочурак
разом з Августином Волошиним,
а на другій ми бачимо колону карпатських
січовиків, які вирушають на фронт.
Світлину було зроблено поблизу будівлі
Головної Команди «Карпатської Січі»
приблизно 14-15 березня 1939 року.
Зверніть увагу, у що вони одягнуті?
Чим вони озброєні?
Вони фактично в домашньому
одязі, вони не мають зброї,
але вони готові дати відсіч.
«Карпатська Січ» спробувала
захопити чеські арсенали,
при цьому загинуло
102 карпатських січовиків,
але зброї вони здобули в іншому місці
хто з чим був – з пістолетами,
з рушницями (старими чи новими)
вони рушили на фронт.
Жорстокі бої відбувалися під Хустом.
Зрозуміло, що хлопці не змогли стримати
готову до війни угорську армію.
У цих нерівних боях загинуло майже
півтори тисячі карпатських січовиків.
На допомогу їм прийшли хлопці
з Галичини, із Волині,
проте втримати не змогли
незалежну Карпатську Україну.
Бої триватимуть у Карпатських
горах іще до травня місяця,
проте Угорщина окупувала
Карпатську Україну.
Уряд Карпатської України емігрував.
Цю світлину було зроблено в Румунії,
тут зображений Августин Волошин
і уряд Карпатської України.
Один з учасників «Карпатської Січі»,
ідучи в бій, написав таку записку:
«Коли вже не має розумного
виходу з тяжкого становища,
то треба вміти вмерти по-геройськи,
щоб така смерть була
джерелом сили для молодих поколінь».
Мабуть, так вже в нас повелося в Україні,
що захищати свою державу
перш за все йдуть добровольці.
Те, що робили карпатські
січовики в 1939 році,
продовжили наші хлопці в 2014 році,
ідучи відстоювати волю
і незалежність нашої держави.
Героїчний спротив Української
Карпатської Республіки
був потоплений у крові
угорськими солдатами.
Українська проблема вкотре
була принесена в жертву
геополітичним інтересам
могутніх європейських гравців,
проте ідея української
державності не згасла.
Отже, давайте підведемо
підсумок нашого уроку.
За яких обставин з'явилася
Карпатська Україна.
Мюнхенська угода,
розчленування Чехословаччини.
І щоб не втратити повністю всю державу,
Чехословаччина дає згоду
на автономію Карпатської України.
Автономія Карпатської України була
проголошена 9 жовтня 1938 року.
15 березня 1939 року в умовах
чергової угорської агресії
було проголошено незалежність
Карпатської України.
І хоч проіснувала вона недовго,
але дала приклад всім українцям,
як боротися за свою державу,
як відстоювати свої інтереси.
Ваше домашнє завдання.
Повторити пройдене, прочитати
параграф «Карпатська Україна»,
дізнатися більше про учасників
«Карпатської Січі».
На все добре!